it is time for hatred mail hatred mail
in 2020 becoming increasingly
belligerent hard to believe given the
last seven years of it but it is
happening
quick reminder what is hatred mail so
what if the president's been accused of
sexual harassment 15 times or that he
paid hush money to a porn star at least
he never wore a tan suit patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay and let's get in directly
to this week's hatred mail episode what
a loser this stupid David Pakman is
total liar slanderer David Pakman is the
poster boy for the leftist super
progressive politically correct
sensitive snowflakes God again I doubt
this scrawny loser has a single black
friend David beta Pakman you are so big
ly wrong no collusion loser sad you are
a bitter uneducated racist selfish loser
the black friend thing is kind of funny
to me you would think that someone who
questions how many black friends I have
would be a leftist saying hey it's
important to have you know a diverse
group of friends or something like that
but I think that when right-wingers ask
how many black friends do you have of a
left winger I think generally they're
making a racist point like you might
defend minorities on your show but you
don't actually want to be around
minorities or something like that
anybody experienced this before I think
that's the gist of right wingers asking
left wingers do you have any black
friends I'm speculating but maybe
someone can interpret for me remember
that the best way to fight the hatreds
is to use the coupon code hey tree at 40
when you sign up for a membership on my
website join pakman.com the coupon code
hey tree at 40 saves you 40% patriots
just start crying whenever that coupon
code is used because they know that they
are impotent in their patriotic attacks
that coupon code of course is spelled h
80
r io t 4 0